a powerful moment captured at a black
lives matter protest in Whitefish
Montana check out this photo you can see
here Samantha Francine staring into the
eyes of a white man identified as Jason
Oden who is just inches from her face
video shows Snowden aggressively
confronting and threatening
demonstrators Francine tells me she
never thought once of backing down but
then I was like oh my gosh
that's me in that photo and a lot of
comments that came after that we're like
can you believe this picture it isn't
funny funny you know this looks like
this is to be during the civil rights
movement why is this happening now I
wish I didn't have to eat that photo I
wish that the world was right since I'm
in that photo I want to own it and I
want to live it I told Francine that her
photo of intolerance from 2020 sadly
reminded me of this one from 1957 it
shows Elizabeth Eckford surrounded by an
angry and screaming white mob as she's
denied entry to Little Rock Central High
School in Arkansas and Gail Francine
told me she was only just starting to
find her voice as a young black woman in
this world where mr. Snowden tried to
drown it out but in this moment and with
this image now seen around the world her
voice has been amplified you know I
think I think number one she is amazing
exceptional young woman she said
everybody who's yelled at her or
embarrassed her is led her to this
moment but this is what I think is so
cool about her she sent a gift basket to
his wife to his wife to mr. Snowden's
wife to let her know I know that she
does not embody what her husband stands
for I think she is truly we have not
heard the last of her GLAAD